[موسيقى]
بكت فتيات المدارس في مارس الماضي
تكرر المشهد بعد تسعه اشهر طالبات الجامعه
طالبان ساوت بينهم لامراه ستعلم لا في
المدارس ولا في الجامعه
طالبان تعهدت بالا يتاثر تعليم الفتيات
بعد تسلمها السلطه وتبرر الان خطواتها لما
تراعي الفتيات الحجاب ولا عدم الاختلاط
بالشباب وبعض المناهج مهينه لكرامه المراه
خاصه الهندسه والزراعه هنا وزير التعليم
العالي في طالبان ندى محمد نديم يتحدث
وائل المفارقه هذا الطالبان يرسلون بناتهن
للتعلم في الخارج فيما تلتحق بعضا من هنا
الى المدارس
التاليه الحركه منقمه في داخلها بسبب هذه
القرارات القرار جاء مباشره
من هبه الله اخنزه ده بمباركه من رئيس
القضاء ووزير الشؤون الدينيه وهناك من
عارض في العالم كنائب وزير الخارجيه الشيخ
محمد عباس الثاني زايد رجل الدين في
طالبان ايضا رحمه الله حقاني قبل مقتله
على يد داعش لاحقا هو الاخر شدد ان كل
الكتب الدينيه نصت على ان التعليم الاناث
الزمي اعتراضات داخليه وصل صداها للشعب
ايضا والاحتجاجات لم تكن نسائيه بحتها كما
نشاهد هناك الشباب تضامنوا مع زميلاتهم
وانسحبوا من امتحاناتهم
ووسط هذه التظاهرات والتمديد الدولي
للقرارات هناك معترض جديد وهنا مفارقه
اخرى
ايران
تعليم الفتيات في افغانستان